[Musik]
herr spahn
können sie mir den impfstoff besorgen
bitte kommen sie mir den impfstoff
besorgen ich möchte zuerst geben werden
wir jungen leute wollen wieder party
machen auf den ersten blick fallen sie
nicht unter risikogruppe ich empfehle
einfach eine ausbildung in der pflege
dann geht schnell ja aber gut zdf unser
zielpublikum dass es auch eine art
pflege job den wir haben von dem
publikum wahrscheinlich dürften viele
sicher zu beginn im winter sind das
stimmt
[Musik]
herr professor ulrich sie sind
epidemiologe ich habe ein anliegen ich
möchte dass die jungen leute zuerst den
impfstoff kriegen können sie mich da
unterstützen
ja haben also die idee ist ja durchaus
gar nicht so von der hand zu weisen wenn
man nämlich die jungen menschen zuerst
impft dann hat man die ganzen super
sprayer die potenziellen ausgeschaltet
und dann würde man ihn direkt damit auch
die risikogruppen schützen also
eigentlich ist der ansatz gerade bei gut
schützen den impfstoffen gar nicht so
verkehrt
können sie das jetzt noch mal einen
kurzen satz sagen und dass junge leute
direkt durch fabian köster ersetzen
[Musik]
können wir so machen sie besorgen wir
den impfstoff und dürfen sich dafür eine
frage aussuchen ich musste das noch mal
sagen damit sie es verstehen dass wir
brauchen da mehrere anläufe ich werde
ihnen keinen stopp das ist zurück und
auch keinen besorgen könne
über party man wissen sich seit wann ich
keine party gemacht habe das ist keine
party gemacht habe ja mein mitleid hält
sich in grenzen
haben sie schon irgendwas vielleicht im
labor was vielleicht nur halb fertig ist
was sie mir trotzdem schon stürzen
können der russische impfstoff wird ja
schon verabreicht und der hat einen
schlechten ruf weil er eben schon ohne
die ergebnisse der phase 3 verimpft wird
aber er ist eigentlich ein sehr
konventionelle ansatz also das heißt
etwas sehr verlässliches könnte ich ihre
impfdosis bekommen weil sie können ja
vielleicht in russischen nehmen
ja ich sag ja wenn er genügend
durchgetestet ist so da bin ich beim
russischen nicht so sicher ob da wurde
schon an putins tochter getestet das ist
so ein bisschen wie russisches roulette
hätten sie denn kontakte nach russland
dass ich da irgendwie rankommen kann ja
wir haben wissenschaftlich
kooperationsprojekte mit russischen
partnern die wir immer noch aufrecht
erhalten und durchführen und das ist
also sehr gut also kann ich mir den
russischen impfstoff ohne bedenken
spritzen lassen
ja natürlich muss keine angst haben ich
meine satiremagazin dass er noch wie
traktoren ist wohl nicht ich weiß nicht
auf welcher liste sieht möglicherweise
stehen bei den russen aber die afg ist
doch sowas wie die geistige tochter von
wladimir putin nicht meinen sie der
würde uns folgen das würde ich toll
finden
ja also das hier ist echt cool sie
werden es bereuen wenn sie jetzt
weggehen ich durchsuche ihren müll wenn
sie jetzt weggehen
das sales plan
merkel wird zuerst geschossen ja das
würde ich die möglichkeit bekommen dann
klappt das ja das erste mal für meine
gesundheit würde der partie das ist von
wegen wasser auf junger mann die
sozialdemokratische partei deutschlands
ist weit über 150 jahre alt hat viele
silva risikogruppe weise luther wir
sehen weiter über 150 jahre alt und habe
vieles überlebt lauterbach was machen
sie hier sie müssen zu langes los die
zeit rennt was habe ich noch da bin ich
noch rechtzeitig aber es wird höchste
zahl ist viel wichtiger
das war es eigentlich mehr wollte ich
die gar nicht fragen als dann machen
sich jetzt auf den weg
ja wir haben jetzt sehr wissenschaftlich
auch geredet vielleicht noch mal einfach
kurz und knackig gesagt warum die jungen
leute zuerst geimpft werden sollten
ja also ich würde sagen wäre ein konzept
was man auch mathematische modellieren
kann wie gut schmerzen hat schnitt habe
schlitz und damit zurück ins studio
es sollte schon so bleiben mit den alten
zuerst ja das ist schon der schnitt
genauso anderem ein arschgeigen solo war
doch versprochen
ihr könnt ja in der zeit den kanal
abonnieren
[Musik]